[Music]
see this time you're good to go
so any apologies
for our meeting
yes i've got an apology i've got to
leave um at 10 40 um
today
well um i've got another meeting we
won't be going
counselor brian and if
and there's an apology for council
williams if we're going beyond 940
moved by deputy mayor atkinson seconded
by councillor redmond all in favor
please say raise your hands
against uh right let's carry um we're
now into reports 3.1
uh which is the cover 19 best pass so um
uh this yeah i think you're leading us
on this report thank you
thank you mr may good morning
councillors thank you for joining us on
this extraordinary meeting this morning
i'm here to present the report with
regards to the vaccine possible vaccine
past removal for the aquatic facilities
libraries and community facilities
so you'll remember i came to you
earlier this year to
update you with regards to the vaccine
pass entry for the aquatic facilities
and the library and that has been very
successful successfully received over
the last few months
by both staff and many of our community
residents
last week you will note that there was
an update from the government
announcement that they will be removing
my vaccine passes from 11 59 on monday
the 4th of april
so vaccine passes were only meant to be
temporary and a review is now
appropriate due to the high coverage of
vaccination within the community and
there is also an increased immunity from
natural infection
there have been mixed emotions across
the community towards the use of my
vaccine passes with a number of
residents choosing to voice their
approval or otherwise to both elected
members and staff over the past few
months
i come to you today with our
recommendation to remove passes in line
with the government advice from 11 59 on
monday the 4th of april including the
removal of the qr code scanning for
aquatic facilities libraries and our
community facilities
these facilities will continue to review
their programs over the coming months to
ensure that appropriate risk mitigation
is in place while omicron is still high
in our community
for staff we will also continue to be
reviewing our risk assessments which
will commence with a full risk
assessment review starting from next
week to ensure that all other
mitigations are appropriately in place
for roles particularly high-risk roles
including physical distancing mask
wearing remote working where possible
and all other good hygiene practices
at that point i'll probably take the
report as read and open up for any
questions thank you
thanks liz uh questions so if you use
the reactions um
i see counselor duty and then counselor
council duty
thank you just a question with the um
stadium
main power stadium how does is does that
go completely separate or from no main
power stadium will also remove their
vaccine past requirements from 11 59.
right thank you
council bond
yes thank you for your report liz um
just with regards to staff
if there are people who are high risk or
feel that they are still concerned with
the high levels of omicron in our
community
um
and they work in a high-risk environment
will all possible measures be taken to
maintain their working status or or
redistribute them to another working
area
thank you for that kirsten it's a really
great question so on tuesday we will be
looking at we've updated our risk
assessment profile there are additional
four questions now that work safe are
looking for us to include which reflects
the new situation that omicron is
presenting to us so we will be reviewing
our risk assessments for all roles
especially those ones that are high risk
and making sure that we're doing
everything that we can to keep our staff
safe so yes including redeployment if
that is is required
thank you
for any further questions
well from the chair i'm going to move
the recommendations of 3.1 as listed is
there a seconder
are you a quick you're second to get
paul is that right
okay
just in speaking to it
we always
maintained that we would review this
situation
uh including the advice from the
ministry
of health and watch the announcements
closely so that we're in a position
to respond quickly
as the situation improves
and based on the information provided by
the government and that's exactly the
position
we're in today
i support
us lowering
the restrictions but i really would like
to still urge our community
to not become complacent with covert 19.
there are a number of cases
um still being presented
we're not sure if where it had reached a
peak
some instances i was told yesterday that
might be the case but we're still not
clear on that so
it's really important that
our community do still practice good
hygiene and the wear masks where needed
and and follow the guidance on self
isolation and importantly
it's a really important time that we
show respect and tolerance to each other
because it is a particularly trying
circumstance for everyone
putting place um putting in place the
restrictions was never an easy decision
for our council to make and we know
we had mixed reactions about doing so
when we met pre-christmas
um but it's one that was based on the
best health information and advice of
the time and that i'd really like to
acknowledge the efforts that our staff
have put in in particular liz i think
you've done an absolutely superb job
through this time advising
the organization both internally and
externally and made sure that the likes
of myself and and jim have excellent
advice and that we are ultimately
protecting our staff and community
because that's what this has been about
have a large range of comments from
people both externally
[Music]
particularly externally and appreciate
those who've made that decision not to
vaccinate it's been a particularly
difficult time for them so i'm sure
these announcements will be welcomed
uh in that regard
um
but it's the right time to make this
call it's in line with the government um
guidelines and advice so i support the
recommendations
um second of which is paul did you wish
to speak
yeah no thank you it's all been said by
dan so well said thank you
thanks paul council duty
thank you i'd just like to pass on liz
um i went up into jp duty at oxford and
i was very impressed with the way that
the staff had handled the situation up
there um you know making sure that we
meet our distance and
and um it's very because it's just in a
small room and i really was most
appreciative of the work they've got
that they have done to make it safe for
anybody that's coming in so i just want
to pass that message on to the staff
thank you
thanks wendy any further speakers
let's say i wait i don't think i've got
anything i need to respond to there so
it's all been well said so let's put the
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please raise your hands
against
clearly karen
thanks liz and uh if you could pass our
thanks to your team as well and i know
i've been supporting you as well and and
jim is our ce who's also been providing
excellent advice so thank you to you all
thank you man thank you councillors
so uh we now um come to decisions with
the public excluded so
there's a recommendation under four
uh and for the reasons there is someone
prepared to move made by councillor
barnett seconded by
councillor atkinson
i'll put that all those in favor and
raise your hand
[Music]
foreign